uh
bajo altus hello uh this uh press
conference regarding kovitt is being
held in the sir johnny mcdonnell
building in ottawa on friday april 22nd
i'm the moderator greg quinn with market
news international with us today
canada's chief public health officer dr
theresa tam
eoc le administrator chef de la sante
public doctor howard professor dr howard
knew i remind everyone dialed in here to
stick to best practices to minimize
outside noise and i believe we might
have something like an hour for the
session
with that housekeeping done let's begin
with opening remarks doctors the floor
is yours
maxie thank you and bonjour toots
prior to the long weekend
covert 19 remained widespread across
canada with early signs that
transmission may have been nearing a
peak in some jurisdictions
however with disease activity still high
and the ba2 sub lineage now accounting
for over 70 percent of sequence variants
it is still too soon to tell whether our
long weekend activities could lead to
another bump ahead
although concerning the recent rise of
hospitalization rates in several
jurisdictions appears to be manageable
with critical care still trending at low
levels
remain hopeful that the increase in
transmission rates over the past several
weeks will not result in as heavy an
impact on hospitalization trends as seen
during earlier waves
this optimism is grounded in the
knowledge of how better immune
protection
due to overall high vaccine coverage
however maintaining strong protection
against serious illness means keeping
covet 19 vaccinations up to date
vaccination is a cornerstone of public
health and is responsible for saving
more lives in the past 50 years in
canada than any other health
intervention
unfortunately data show there are not
only gaps in coverage for recommended
covert 19 vaccinations but also delayed
or mis-vaccinations for other serious
infectious diseases during the pandemic
so today we want to remind canadians
once again of the importance of staying
up to date with all routine vaccinations
and as tomorrow marks the beginning of
national immunization awareness week in
canada we want to reinforce the
importance of vaccinations in protecting
our health throughout our lives this is
also an opportunity to thank canada's
healthcare workforce immunizers
volunteers community workers and
researchers for all the work they've
done and continue to do so to build a
healthier canada through immunization
likewise we want to extend thanks to
canada's immunization partnership fund
or ipf recipients
supporting community-based initiatives
led by organizations like these has
helped increase vaccine confidence and
improve vaccination access and uptake
from the ground up
throughout the largest and perhaps most
complex immunization campaign in
canada's history
rolling out covert 19 primary series and
boosted those programs to provide
canadians with a strong foundation of
protection
ipf organizations have played vital and
innovative roles
these organizations use local knowledge
tailored outreach and community
interventions to reach underserved and
under vaccinated populations to reduce
barriers to vaccination by addressing
information gaps and improving access
for example
digital public square is receiving ipf
funding to support the development of
its online platform and tools to dispel
rumors and encourage viral sharing of
credible health information
trusted health resources including an
interactive coronavirus quiz are used to
counter covert 90 misinformation while
challenging users to achieve top
knowledge rankings and share the cover
19 know-how with others
science north is another ipf supported
project that is working to provide a
comprehensive program of virtual and
in-person activities in english and
french to support vaccine decision
making
this project will include a public
health expert podcast series and
webinars for students parents and
caregivers as well as in-person hands-on
exhibits and workshops for family
audiences across northern ontario
with covert 19 still circulating widely
in canada vaccines plus remain our
main public health mantra
personal precautions like masking
improving ventilation and staying home
if we have symptoms or test positive are
still important to reduce spread
at the same time it is very important to
maintain a strong core of protection
against severe illness by getting up to
date with covert 19 vaccines including
booster doses
although there is uncertainty in the
months ahead
both for the trajectory of kovic 19 and
for other respiratory viruses like
influenza that have been less common due
to strong public health measures
the importance of vaccination is clear
to be prepared with the best possible
protection against serious illness due
to one or more of these diseases now is
a crucial time for catching up with all
recommended vaccinations that help keep
us healthy from childhood through
adolescence and adulthood thank you
merci megwic
bonjour
twist hello everyone
canada
thank you merci uh we'll turn to some
questions now um
christian noel canada
canada
questions
um
um
secondly let's turn now to uh glenn
mcgregor ctv
oh hi there just uh following up on
christian's question there about
travelers uh the united states has
scrapped its
mass mandate for
domestic air travel
many of the provinces are going to be
doing the same thing in the coming weeks
and it will soon be in a situation where
for most canadians the only place
they'll be legally required to wear a
mask is on an airplane and i'm just
wondering how long you think that is
necessary whether that's even still
effective uh and and do you anticipate
um this spring sometime or early summer
that the requirement to wear masks on
either domestic or international flights
uh will be scrapped
yes it's theresa time i'll take that
question and i think this uh this kind
of requirement requires ongoing
evaluation right now of course within
the canadian context omicron ba2 is
going strong
and so and you're going to be traveling
with a group of people in a
a certain environment
i think it is prudent to continue to
require wearing a mask
again it takes a guesswork out of you
know the traveler everybody's going to
be wearing a mask it's an additional
layer of protection it can reduce
transmission why not i mean it has a
certain amount of inconvenience perhaps
but it does not essentially restrict
travel as such so i think it's um it's a
one of the least intrusive
but
measures but adds definitely another
layer of protection but i think
you know one has always got to
reevaluate policies over time including
the epidemiologic
situation
in canada and
overseas as well
also on flights i mean i know you've
been asked many times about whether or
not you think three vaccine doses of a
booster dose
should be the definition of fully
vaccinated but at least for the purposes
of air travel given what we know about
the
the uh decline and effectiveness of just
the two dose regimen
should three doses not now be required
in order to fly
first of all what you said is really
important and any adult 18 plus should
go and get a booster um and everyone
should get their vaccine up to date
based on your eligibility so that's
really important and as i said ba2
omicron is going strong and there's
activities all over the world
so get your booster
in terms of an actual requirement on the
other hand that's a policy that needs to
be examined and it is it will be
examined by our decision makers the the
ministers in charge so
um i think for sure three doses in the
era of omicron uh is really important to
have
whether you require or not that's a
different policy
uh decision and an
analysis but any traveler before you go
traveling overseas or even across canada
please go and get boosters that's gonna
really help protect you but also others
around you
thank you uh sweet uh michelle
laplace canadian
protection
[Music]
foreign
uh
foreign
uh next turn to dylan robertson the
winnipeg free press dylan
hi there i'm unmuted now um thanks for
taking our questions uh dr tim i just
want to ask you about the three prairie
provinces laking behind everyone else
for booster shot uptake and second dose
uptake the demand seems to have dried up
there are super sites being closed you
can still get shots in a doctor's office
but it seems few people are asking for
that so i'm wondering if you have any
concerns about one region being behind
everyone else especially when they're
over represented in hospitalizations
right now and what we should do about
that
i think a
very multifaceted approach is needed
to increase the booster rates
particularly for adults over 50 but
depending on your risk factors but
anyone over the age of eight 18
years of age and older nasty now
recommends that you get a booster shot
with a general interval of six six
months
um i think
right now i
with the omicron ba2 wave still very
much active
this is a good time for people to
actually get vaccinated so but but it
does take
many different approaches
and some of which we've actually talked
about
in our opening remarks is getting
community organizations who
can have a reach that perhaps
governments
by themselves cannot do into different
community figuring out why is it that
they're not getting vaccinated uh is it
because they didn't don't understand the
importance of the um third dose is it
because they think if they got just got
vaccinated how long they should wait to
get the boosters those questions may
need to be answered in different
languages and so i think those community
programs will be really vital
certainly having access points that are
convenient going to where the people are
to help them
get access in the most readyly
available
approach would still be important
but i think um
you know this all chief medical officers
right now trying to um
re-communicate with everybody about the
concepts of up-to-date vaccination
so um i think we have to explain to
everyone that because of omicron
which is a immune evasive variant yes
you read that third dose is really
important
and it can give you a boost in
reduction against infection at least for
periods of time and transmission to
others but it can we also strengthen the
immunity against severe outcomes and
most of the vaccine effectiveness study
shows that you get a over 90 vaccine
effectiveness against omicron for severe
outcomes so what you were saying like
icus and hospitalization rates being
still high in certain provinces don't
seem to be coming down very fast
please do and go and get that booster
because it is very very effective
i think are we concerned yeah we would
love to get people mobilized once again
to like they did the first round and the
second round to get that booster dose we
probably haven't done enough good
communication uh from from all angles
public health and otherwise and so we're
we're trying to do that once again and
and give it another shot as it were
but do you
you know obviously contact your local
jurisdictions as to how how you get that
shot in but but we do need to um
i think
again
get another boost of energy uh for
canadians to to get that booster of
course if you're in a really high-risk
group including um the most senior of
our population a fourth dose or a second
booster is also available
and we we are seeing the fourth dose
rates going up faster perhaps than our
our third dose
and so we would like to encourage
everybody to get that very important
that those
thank you and uh on a totally different
note i wanted to ask about overdoses uh
manitoba recently reported data that
drug-related deaths have more than
doubled in the past four years it's not
as bad as bc but this trend seems to be
heading east across the prairies
as it has been for a number of years
there's been talk about
decriminalization of drugs locally and
i'm wondering how that fits in as a tool
if decriminalization is helpful if it's
a silver bullet or if it's a
counterproductive idea
so dylan you you hit on a really really
important public health crisis that
i hope everybody is aware of
during the panama itself the substance
used opi or multi multi substance use
related crisis has escalated due to i
think multiple factors
uh connection is very important for
individuals who use drugs and some of
that connection was lost perhaps during
the pandemic and access to harm
reduction services we need a holistic
approach to reducing
uh substance use related harms and the
deadly effects of some of the drugs that
are
currently circulating
and that is a whole range of prevention
but harm reduction
access to safer supplies that's
something that health canada and the
federal government's been trying to do
is to set up
a number of projects and programs across
the country uh to see uh the
effectiveness of this for the provision
of saver supplies because of just how
toxic the drug supply is right now
decriminalization
serves to reduce stigma
and
really help
focus the fact that substance use is a
public health issue
and not one of um criminalization issue
um so i think that's the most important
aspect of decriminalization but it
cannot be
um you know a single measure it's not a
silver bullet you have to have all the
other
full
multi-layered approach including
prevention harm reduction safer supply
treatments recovery
and of course social and economic
support measures to address the
determinants of health but i think
different approaches
best
leveraging the
i think knowledge base of the community
of persons who use drugs and their
families that's really important in
finding solutions
but i know that a lot of cities as well
as provinces are currently examining
the
policy of decriminalization and applying
to health canada
on that matter
thank you merci uh next up uh news of
milan klit press
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
um
um
um
later this year
uh
[Music]
i believe we have one more question here
laura osmond canadian press
another three hours [ __ ] off hi doctors
um i want to start by asking you about
hospitalizations dr tam you mentioned
that so far hospitalizations are
remaining manageable i'm wondering if
you're noting a situation that we saw
during omicron where
hospitals were still feeling overwhelmed
not because of the number of
hospitalizations but because so many
health workers had to be off sick
there was a bit of noise online but um
yes i think according to my colleagues
in the parliaments and territories
uh one of the um issues that um not as
bad as in the first omicron wave but
there's still a significant impact of
the
current resurgence on health care worker
absenteeism
so they may not be very sick but if you
get test positive you're going to have
to stay away from work for a period of
time
and because of activities in the
community health workers also have
families who may be positive so there
could be contacts in the household and
other settings so yes that is
one of the factors
that can impact the health system
capacity at the moment
and
which is why i think everyone needs to
continue to do all that we can to reduce
transmission
in order to protect the health system at
the moment i think in some jurisdictions
they're managing but really stress the
system is stressed
um our modeling
is projecting still an increase in
hospitalization
but probably not as bad as the initial
omicron wave as we said throughout our
remarks we have to see what happened
over the long weekend
i hope people actually went and got
boosted
and
didn't spend a lot of time in spreading
um omicron to others so we will see what
happens
over the long weekend just to
have a better idea of what the impact
on the health system would be in the
next couple of weeks
perfect thank you
i also want to turn now to travel with
these small changes the government seems
to be signaling that they want to take a
more sustainable approach to
restrictions
dr neu i heard you say that
if people are fully vaccinated
then we can start to ease some of these
restrictions but many people are asking
of course for the
vaccine mandates to be dropped or
wondering when that will happen
is it your advice still that that is
sort of the key feature of the travel
restrictions that need to remain in
place
and it's afternoon so ameebic and i can
star and dr time can certainly add to it
but you're right i think at the end of
the day i think everyone
is in agreement that the vaccines are
still our major tool a major layer of
protection and so you know both you know
inside canada for for all canadians but
also for for travel purposes i think
it's important to to stress the point
that you know the higher our vaccine
coverage is uh the better we all are
overall in terms of protecting against
the serious consequences uh of of covet
19 and so uh you know as we move forward
uh certainly it will continue to look at
the evidence the data and adjust as
necessary and uh the one thing i would
say is that you know even with the the
changes that uh have been made with
respect to our border measures and many
of them obviously you can imagine
there's operational considerations as to
why uh you know it's been put in place
now and you know as opposed to maybe uh
you know some other time but it's
important to maintain that
infrastructure so we have things like
testing and so on we want to maintain
that so you know should there
unfortunately maybe a covert 19 takes a
turn for the worst and we need to
readjust and and go back to a different
regime or maybe similar to what we might
have had before we're ready to do that
so so i think that's that's i think the
key feature of what we're doing at the
border trying to remain i think flexible
and nimble as well uh should there need
to be adjustments made but yes i think
at the end of the day not saying
anything but from a policy perspective
but yes uh you know the higher a
vaccination rate is you know the higher
you know uh the uptake is the vaccines
the better overall so that that's all i
will say and it doesn't really matter if
it's related to travel or just uh with
you know within uh within sort of within
canada for for canadians in general
thanks
uh those are all the questions we have
for today so i just like to thank
everyone merci miguet and if you have
any final thoughts please go ahead
go get boosted
thank you
travel safe
thanks everyone
recording stopped